so let's begin with a few words from
greg moore greg is the editor of The
Denver Post and a leader of journalism
in America before just a second Greg I
have more to say before joining the post
in 2002 he spent 16 years at the Boston
Globe the last eight as managing editor
the Cleveland native and a graduate of
Ohio Wesleyan University greg has risen
through the ranks and journalism working
for papers in Ohio before joining the
globe where he served in a variety of
newsroom leadership positions before
becoming managing editor during his
editorship at the Denver Post the paper
has won pulitzer prizes for feature
photography in 2010 and this year and
for editorial cartooning last year the
post also has been a finalist for
breaking news reporting and for
investigative reporting and incidentally
the board has very strict rules on
recusal if a member zone news
organization is a nominee for a prize
that member must recuse himself or
herself totally leaving the room during
any discussion and voting Gregg is
widely respected in 1996 he was named
journalist of the Year by the New
England chapter of the National
Association of Black Journalists he is
the former board member of the American
Society of news editors and has taught
at the Poynter Institute for Media
Studies and the American press Institute
he's been a stalwart member of the
Pulitzer Prize board since 2004 helping
maintain its commitment to excellence in
journalism and the arts ladies and
gentlemen Greg Moore
alright
as six said you're going to be hearing
from my co-chair fellow co chair tom
friedman i just wanted to take a few
seconds to welcome you to the special
occasion on behalf of the board and
everyone associated with the prizes we
were really really glad to see you here
you know it really doesn't get much
better than this the smiles are bright
and broad the wine is flowing Chester
poked out and new bonds are born and
that's just on a personal note but it's
really fitting that the awards in this
luncheon come at this time of year this
is the season of renewal and so it is
for our craft it's an honor and it's a
privilege to read the great work that's
being done in our industry and I know
that everyone engaged in this work comes
away inspired from jurors to board
members themselves it's simply
breathtaking to see the work that makes
it into print and that is published on
our websites and no matter what people
say about the challenges that are facing
our industry our newsrooms are not the
problem so your presence here today
proves once again that fabulous work can
be done anywhere anytime by anyone what
makes this day even more special is that
you can share it with loved ones spouses
and significant others who make so many
sacrifices so that we can do what we do
so here's to you a toast to the people
who really make it happen
and to our winners this is the day that
you will never forget drink it all in
enjoy it and savor it the only thing
that might make this a better make this
better than today is a tomorrow in which
you find yourself sitting here again and
that will mean that you've done
something really amazing for journalism
for your communities and for yourselves
so thank you welcome have a really good
time
with us today I want to introduce a few
other folks with us today our current or
departing members of the Pulitzer board
who helped judge the 2012 prizes I would
like them to rise and be acknowledged
first professor of social science at the
Institute for Advanced Studies in
Princeton New Jersey Danielle Allen the
managing editor for projects and
investigations at the bloomberg news
Robert blau
it's a little shy the senior vice
president and executive editor of The
Associated Press Kathleen Carroll
author journalist and Dean of Columbia
Journalism school Nick lemon
incidentally the journalism school is
100 years old this year and at your
places is a booklet on the 50 greatest
stories covered by Columbia graduates
it's well worth reviewing each year on
the recommendation of Columbia
Journalism school the Pulitzer Prizes
award fellowships of 7,500 dollars to
five top students in the graduating
class the awards allow them to travel
and pursue journalistic projects for are
here today please rise when I call your
name but withhold your applause until
all have been introduced first we have
Lourinha galiyo edwards small Seth
Berkman and Chris boo Ruby
we're also pleased to have with us today
a former Pulitzer Prize board member
who's the chair of International Studies
at the journalism school and his former
interim dean David clay tell and we have
several descendants of Joseph Pulitzer
the founder of the prizes and of the
journalism school we have Victoria
Donaldson Marie Rhea donelson and Bianca
Pulitzer please rise to be acknowledged
finally we want to pay special tribute
to see you I T or q it it's an acronym
for Columbia University information
technology for 95 years news
organizations entered the journalism
competition by sending us bulky
scrapbooks more than a thousand every
season FedEx trucks would circle our
building for days this year we transform
the system the scrapbooks are gone
everything was entered and judged
electronically and it worked beautifully
and the Wizards of cuit were at the
center of this transformation so today
we want to present a certificate of
appreciation for outstanding service to
Q it and the QA team and it's signed by
every member of the Pulitzer Prize board
with us our Candace Fleming vice
president for technology and her team
Patricia Lee Ivan Lucic Jake young and
Chuck I ghen also here is their overall
boss executive vice president jeff scott
candace please come forward to accept a
certificate and the members of the team
also please rise and be acknowledged for
you splendid achievement
you